let's talk about santa clarita diet oh
now what a show okay I don't know where
your attitudes coming from guys watch it
seriously okay okay what's this show
okay this I found it to be very funny
and I'm a friend of yours Oh
start I would still tell the audience it
was good if it wasn't but privately tell
you it sucked but I'm publicly telling
you it's great it's a really funny show
I hope you watch it I told him when he
came out I so you can tell he's serious
about it cuz he's not wearing flip-flops
like you normally I know you actually
wore it houses the mo rest up like a
grown up yeah this is the most dressed
up you've ever been you always come here
like a weed dealer tryna you do you look
like you just stumbled that aspic oles
van i made your way out here I am NOT a
weed dealer I'm not you know my
character in the show a smoke spot
actually yes I know that I am is that
something you try to avoid I'm not a big
possible guy never was there's like you
know as an athlete growing up I didn't
smoke a lot occasional last note the
last real time here's the other thing
weed now it's like some kind of crazy
science it's powerful I've never liked
as a kid you're like look taking seeds
out and you know you're trying to not
get the bad now it's the last time I
smoked weed I was in Austin with my
brother I was there shooting and he's in
the music business we went to Austin
City Limits mm-hmm we've been hanging
out all day drinking and listening to
the bands and then we're backstage and
we're hanging out with the people who
put on the festival and these guys said
you guys want to smoke some weed and I
said no I'm good and they said it's
Willie Nelson's I said light it up
really Nelson's weed yeah his weed
travels before like honest like it gets
there right like if they are four seats
in but then the riders yeah yeah the
good thing and tell us about that what's
Willie really like it's it's actually
technically I believe called Willie weed
Willie weed I think he's Martin it's
like a hold anyway so we had a little
Willie weed I said you know what my
brother said
and easy and I sent two hits
it was at least one hit too many you
know I'm always like watch it you know
I'm swam watch my you know anyway all I
know is it the next thing I was with my
brother and I looked across the lawn
there was a golf cart not ten yards and
I said you know I'm just gonna go I'm
gonna go sit at the golf on that golf
cart and I took like four strides and
said or I'll just sit right here on the
one sitting there on the lawn and I you
know what and this is not false modesty
I do not think of myself as a celebrity
I really don't deal with a lot of that
stuff and it's just not the way I see
mice
when you're high on the lawn you're like
dude you're a celebrity man oh my god
tell my brother I was like dude get a
Sharpie get a ballpoint pen I was like
wise legs you need to write some stuff
down I'm I'm staying at the Four Seasons
I'm in room 327 writing is on your hands
I'm telling them to get me a pen so I
can write it down before yeah yeah yeah
you know I mean yeah because you just
that's what whenever anyone if you get
any time in your life too drunk too high
or anything these pieces of information
are crucial yeah I mean they're like
look I need to get to the Four Seasons
room 327 this is like really important
people understand that yeah because you
know there's a lot of things I'd like to
have in common with Robert Downey jr.
but walking into the wrong home and
falling asleep
that's one way you want to diverge
that's the one place we're like you went
that way I'll look this way
you